hello we begin with breaking news from
the occupied West Bank where three
Palestinians have been killed and
several wounded during a raid by Israeli
forces in the city of nobles the Israeli
Army says two of the victims were
responsible for last month's drive-by
shooting in the Jordan Valley which
killed three Israeli settlers a mother
and her two daughters let's go to
occupied East Jerusalem and speak to
Muhammad jamjun what more are we
learning about this
that I mean we've gotten some more
details uh just in the past several
minutes Israeli Army radio is saying
that there were more than 200 Israeli
soldiers that participated in this raid
that happened in the old city of Nablus
in the occupied West Bank earlier this
morning what we know so far from the
Israeli military is this that those
soldiers went into the old city and
novelist in the occupied West Bank and
that they killed three Palestinian men
the Israeli Army accuses these men of
having been behind the killing of Lucy
Rina and Maya D those are those British
Israeli cities dual citizens that were
settlers they were killed in a drive-by
shooting uh in April on April 7th so
just about a month ago the Israeli Army
says that they conducted a thorough
investigation that they uncovered that
these men according to them were behind
those killings they say that two of the
men actually carried out the killing and
that one of the Palestinian men assisted
in getting weapons and planning the
attack now this is something that is
very worrying for the Israeli government
obviously we have seen almost nightly
raids into the occupied West Bank
carried out by the Israeli military over
the last several months and one of the
reasons for that is because of the fact
that the Israeli government continues to
accuse the Palestinian Authority of not
doing enough to in their words curb
militancy in places like nabulous the
Israeli government keeps saying that
there are these Lone Wolf attackers and
that the Palestinian authorities should
be doing more to make sure that these
people cannot carry out attacks against
Israeli citizens and Israeli settlers we
expect to have more details in the hours
to come we have heard one thing from the
Hassan brigades that is the military
wing of Hamas they issued a statement in
which they praised these three men they
called them Martyrs and they also said
that the killing of these men will not
limit the ability of Hamas or the
Cassandra aids to limit its strikes and
operations or to stop
its attacks we've also heard one
statement from the Palestinian Authority
they have condemned this raid by the
Israeli Army in nabulous this morning
thank you so much reporting from
occupied East Jerusalem